Tyler how did you hear about on the
horizon okay I heard about on the
horizon to my manager he told me he said
he has this great script on his desk
that he thought would be perfect for me
and then he thought that it's something
I could really bring something to and
that was and that was first and foremost
that was the primary attraction to the
script was this idea of being out of
bring something unique to it and and in
reading the words reading the material
that became very apparent to me that
there was a perspective that I could
that I could bring that I felt was
unique and was not necessarily in the
text explicitly but through our
conversations and through our dialogue
we developed and I'll tell you it was
the I remember getting the phone call
from him for the first time in driving
him in LA traffic and they met a passion
that it was from him an excitement I
mean he got yeah it got me excited I
mean I my heart started going and I had
to pull over on the side of the side of
the 101 which is uh which is fairly
illegal but I was in such an intense
conversation with them that um yeah I
just I had so I had to give my full
attention and I knew that I was in safe
hands
the moment that I but I heard his his
enthusiasm and excitement and what was
so funny is that and I think he knew and
I told him is that for me he got the
role even though he did the audition and
even if he didn't kill it because he
kind of went to a wrong direction and
then I focused him back but just from
the conversation on the phone you got it
but I think what one week I made him
wait I make me sit on it yeah for sure
and I at this point that I had really
like I tend to be pretty reserved with
with getting projects like I said trying
to be divorced from the outcome but at
this point I had fought for this one I
had rushed home and and done this Skype
audition where I was screaming at a
screaming on a webcam which is on here
with him on the other end I'm thinking
like it's this guy makes you do all this
but you know again you gotta be prepared
for this business so yeah but that was
the whole point for me I was just trying
to see because I I don't care if it you
have to do the audition in person or the
tape or whatever as long as you bring it
and for him it was about do you listen
to what I'm saying so he did a version I
was just like no do dis instead and I
was kind of direct to him and then I was
reading the text I was like Anna because
the reader that he was was not right
he didn't she that person didn't get the
right tone for the ELISA so when I did
in with him
I was ELISA and then I was like boom
inside of him and then and then but then
for the audition it just worked like
crazy and we did it well three or four
time and but at one point I was just
playing with him I was just went wanted
to see can he still go on and go on and
go on and he was it was always getting
better and better and then I was like
yeah I got it
and just butter just physically fit
Casey and he listened to me and it was
all about passion and I think he felt
the same thing for me and it was
reversal so as soon as I talked to him I
was just like yeah Ian but unfortunately
yeah yeah me wait a little bit but I was
very excited to get on board with this
one
ya know it's so far my career is the
best choice so far so and for me as well
I mean I've never gotten to pour as much
as my heart into something I've never
gotten to I mean like I said went by the
time all the work was done my time we
had done all the preparation there was
not a whole lot of acting on screen and
I mean that in the most positive of
sentences and that it was it felt
effortless because of everything that we
had done up to that point yeah and plus
to you needed to know that you could
work with someone in such close quarters
um you said you had a a crew of like
three people maybe that's another thing
for me is always to find people that I
can be friends with it's not just work
yes it is work but at the same time it's
such a tight crew so it is family it is
like a boyfriend girlfriend whatever
kind of relationship you need to be able
to just because I think most days was
like ten hours a day but then after that
it's having a good time having just you
are with those person 24/7 there's no
trailer or whatever it's like shooting a
documentary live but we have a schedule
so it was just it for me it's a very
intimate process and when it works that
makes something magical and and we had
some real we had some real kismet occur
on on the set
one scene in particular in the in the
white desert here we have this here
abbas without giving anything away we
have this this this whole thing building
and these tensions rising and then on
the horizon there's a storm building and
that and here's this this very
threatening weather coming in and we
only have this day to shoot this scene
we only have this window to shoot it and
and so it's it's go go go we got it we
got to get this done one way or another
and I think if something about that
ticking clock that really got us to the
edge of where we need to get to and
because we had us I had my plan okay now
we're gonna do a wide and it's gonna be
a close up but then we see that we hear
the rumble people and then I see my son
guy with this middle pole in the middle
of the white there's and I was like
there's someone is gonna die is gonna be
dead guys right so and then we see that
storm coming and I'm like yeah we we
don't have time just everything is gonna
be a long long take and the fact that it
was I think it makes them better it
makes their just everything was way more
alive and I think it works with that
thing that there's no interruption and
with the storm coming the cloud was
forming and now I think everything
happens for a reason when you shoot
something like that everything happens
for a reason and it worked I think
that's the best thing of the film it's
like the sense of urgency that we think
that was a result of mother nature
itself which it's like there's no
substitute for that it was incredible we
got lucky
you